big game is this weekend that's exciting
yeah a big football game Andy do you
have any plans to watch the Chiefs and
Niners yeah I usually watch the game at
Stevie's house Oh
oh yeah that's right our cue card guys
Stevie he always hosts these really big
parties Stevie
are you having people over this year
yeah you guys should come with just uh
one thing this year
no guac what do you mean no guac yeah
your homemade guacamole is the best part
of your parties I mean your guac is
legendary I know I know but until
somebody invents avocado hand insurance
homemade guac is just too risky remember
what happened in my last Super Bowl
party yeah y'all better take cover
because Steve is about to drop a rock
bomb on you
[Applause]
oh yeah I forgot about that because you
also forgot about my I love the 90s
costume party last month jiggy with some
guac bracelets
[Applause]
yeah now I remember that did you ever
find that hand and it's on my to-do list
yeah okay
yeah that that was pretty bad not as bad
as my Sex in the City series finale
party and that was a dream compared to
my everyone wears something you wore to
one of my other parties party hey who's
ready for some homemade guac
and I'm I'm really sorry Stevie yeah me
too but have you heard about holy
guacamole holy guacamole
yeah that's what I just said holy
guacamole I mean it's it's like having
avvocato hand insurance check this out
have you suffered an avocado related
injury don't risk it holy guacamole is
refrigerated and pre scooped for your
protection
it's like avocado hand insurance in your
fridge holy guacamole it's not a real
insurance company but it is made with
real avocados also this is not my real
voice it actually sounds like this wow I
guess we can't guac and roll at my party
after all
yeah I'm just glad to see your guac in
action holy guacamole Conan those buns
were terrible who are you
none of your beeswax
[Music]
we have a great show for you we really
do
sponsored the come on up here Robin
Robin come on up keep dancing keep
dancing stars of the eights keep it
going as fast as you can
stars of the HG TV series
propertybrothers no I'm not dancing
Jonathan and drew Scott here within a
break we'll be right back
[Applause]
you